so I'm going to talk about artificial
intelligence and the work we're doing at
deep mind especially concentrating on
our most recent work over the last sort
of year so I've titled this talk
exploring the frontiers of knowledge
this is what I think we've been doing in
a number of domains now in the last 12
to 18 months so for those of you don't
know deep minds company founded in 2010
in London and we think of the company as
a kind of Apollo program effort for
artificial intelligence so we have over
400 research engineers and scientists
more than 250 PhDs and I think it's the
biggest collection of scientific sort of
brain power anywhere in the world focus
on this topic what we try to do as well
is create a new way of organizing
science so you can think of the
environment at deep mind as a kind of
hybrid between the best of academia and
academic labs combined with the
intensity and the focus of the best
startups the best Silicon Valley
startups so we try to fuse those two
cultures together and try and take the
best from both now in 2014 we joined
Google to turbocharge our mission and
the way we articulate our mission is in
a two-step process so step one try and
fundamentally solve intelligence both
understand natural intelligence and we
create it artificially and then once you
have that technology step 2 we think
naturally follows use it to solve
absolutely everything else now that may
seem a little bit fanciful to you but I
hope by the end of this talk you'll be
convinced that this is at least
plausible once we created this kind of
technology so more prosaically the way
we think about our mission is to build
the world's first general-purpose
learning system so we really stress the
two words general and learning so all
the algorithms and the systems we build
at deep mind are learning and learn have
learning at their heart so they learn
how to master tasks directly from raw
experience or raw data they're not told
anything about the system the
environment mentallity and they have
learn everything from first principles
the second thing is this idea of
generality the idea that one single
system with one set of algorithms
out-of-the-box can operate across a wide
range of environments so can transfer
their knowledge from one domain to
another domain seamlessly of course we
have an example of such a
general-purpose learning system it's the
human brain and that's why the mind we
also have a whole group that looks at
neuroscience to try and be inspired by
neuroscience in the way the brain works
to think of new architectures and
algorithms that might work for machine
learning so our first big breakthrough
happened about two or three years ago
now and what we did is a deep mind we
use virtual environments like games as a
training ground for testing our AI
algorithms on games are the perfect
training ground for this because in a
way they're kind of microcosms of
real-life what we're interested in is
artificial agents that can achieve goals
and process at their perception inputs
around them and build models of the
world they find themselves in to achieve
a certain task or a certain goal so
games are very good for this and we
started off with the iconic game from
the 80s the atari games and actually our
first big piece of work which was
featured in nature was to have build a
system that could play any Atari game
directly from the pixel input only
receiving the pixel inputs as the only
data it would receive so it has to
figure out for itself what the rules of
the game are and how to score points and
it does this by a process of trial and
error and actually experiencing the game
for itself but today I'm going to talk
about our more recent work on a system
called alphago now alphago is a program
designed to play the ancient game board
game of go now for those of you don't
know what go is this is what the board
looks like go is played on a 19 by 19
grid and there's two players black and
white and they take turns to play stones
on the board once a stone is placed it's
not moved anymore just stays where it is
and the board starts off empty and
gradually fills up
now the aim of the game is to surround
your opponents tones or surround and
wall off empty areas of territory and
the end of the game might look something
like this board configuration and then
you count up the areas that you
surrounded and you add up up to the
number of stones that you've captured it
from your opponent and the person that
has the player that has the most points
wins the game now the thing about go is
that it only has two rules I could teach
you the game in five minutes but it
leads to incredible complexity it's
probably the most elegant game that
mankind has ever devised and in fact the
history of go is a long and storied one
it's over 3,000 years old and originated
in China and it's what they play in Asia
instead of chess in fact it's more
popular than chess and it's more deeply
ingrained in the culture so today
there's more popular than ever there's
40 million active players and over 2,000
professionals people who make their
living only from playing go and those
2,000 professionals come from a whole
series of go schools what happens in
Asia in Korea in Japan or in China is if
you show promise in the gamers go of at
the age of sort of five or six or seven
you get taken out of Normal School and
you get put in to go school where you
study go 12 hours a day seven days a
week with your peers who are also trying
to become professional go players so
this is taken really seriously and it's
been like this for hundreds of years now
one way to illustrate the complexity of
the game is that there are not more
board configurations in the gamers go
than there are atoms in the universe so
there's 10 to the power 170 possible
board configurations so there's no way
that you can solve this game through
brute force calculation it's much too
complex even if you took all the compute
power in the world and you ran it for a
million years that wouldn't be enough
compute power to calculate all the
variations and go
and that's one of the reasons that makes
go so hard for computers to play it's
taken 20 years since deep-blue famously
beat Garry Kasparov in 1997 at the game
of chess and ever since then cracking
the game ago has been one of the Holy
Grails of AI research and there's two
reasons has been so hard one is this
complexity I just talked about so the
search basing go is really huge what we
refer to as the branching factor of a
game and Ingo in an average position
there are 200 possible moves if you
compare that to chess in an average
position in a chess game there are only
20 possible moves so there's an order of
magnitude more possibilities every move
in the gamers go the second big
challenge even bigger challenge is that
it was thought impossible until alphago
came along to write down an evaluation
function to tell the system who is
winning whether it's black or white and
by how much now an evaluation function
is critical to a computer system to play
any game so in order for it to decide
which amongst the many possibilities is
the best one for it and the worst one
for its opponent so and go for 20 or 30
years now people have been trying to
write handcrafted pre-programmed
evaluation functions like they do in
chess to describe to the system who's
winning
but Ingo because there's no concept of
materiality all the pieces are worth the
same there's just this concept of a
stone it's very difficult to write a
function directly that tells the system
who's winning so how do humans human
professionals and the best player human
players cope with this enormous
complexity in these two problems well
actually they use they rely on their
intuition and their instinct much more
so than chess players do so chess is
really a game about calculation if you
ask a professional chess player why they
made a certain move they'll usually tell
you I thinking a would happen then I was
going to do B and then I thought C would
happen so they usually have an explicit
plan now that plan may not turn out to
be good at the end of the day but they
usually can tell explain to explicitly
why they've made a move now and go it's
very different if you ask the top
professional player in a complex game
why they played a move they might just
tell you it
felt right and they'll use those words
so they're really using their intuition
and instinct rather than calculation so
how did we overcome this problem in our
system alphago well we turned to deep
neural networks to kind of capture this
intuitive aspect of go we train two
neural networks actually one called a
polity network that took a board
position in and out put a probability
distribution describing the likelihood
of each of the possible moves on the
board and what that means is instead of
having to search out 200 possible moves
every position you can just look at the
top five or six most probable ones and
the second thing we did is after week we
we improve the system by having the
system play against itself millions of
times and over a matter of months and
each time learnings incrementally from
its mistakes through a process of trial
and error called reinforcement learning
and incrementally getting better with
each practice game much like humans do
and through that process we were able to
build a second-year network called a
value net which took a board position in
the default position in blue at the
bottom here and output a single number a
real number between zero and one
which was the system's prediction about
who was winning the game zero being
wiped completely winning 1 being black
knee completely winning and point 5
meaning an equal an equal game so this
value net this pink neural network here
on the left is is the fabled evaluation
function but instead of programming it
directly
we got the system to learn it for itself
so I haven't got time to go into the
technical details but if you're
interested you can read our nature front
cover article on this that came out
earlier this year sorry last year so we
took this system and we wanted to test
it bring it to the ultimate sort of
challenge and in March of last year we
took on a legend of the game
the south korean grandmaster lee sedol
he's won 18 world titles in his widely
acknowledged to be the greatest player
of the past decade and we played this
match in seoul five-game match for a
million dollars first prize and the
whole of korea basically
came to Santa chol at one point every
national TV broadcaster was broadcasting
the match live all all of the different
TV channels so we played this game is
amazing once-in-a-lifetime experience
and we managed to win to everyone's
surprise the match for one and this was
described and proclaimed there's a
decade before its time from the AI
experts and the NGO experts and that's
very unusual for all of you involved in
technology for something to happen a
decade before it was predicted in
technology and engineering but more
importantly than the fact that alphago
won this match was how it won and I just
want to take a moment to try and explain
to you some of the innovations that
alphago came up with so in the game of
Go there are every now and again every
sort of twenty years as famous games are
played where a move so astounding as
played is recorded for all history is
written about in the in the go books and
it's sort of regarded as a sort of
mystical move and I think in this
five-game match there were several moves
like that but this is my favorite one
this is a position from game 2 and this
is mu 37 alphago is black and Lisa Dahl
is white and alphago played this move
here on the right hand side marked by
the white triangle so it's called a
shoulder hit because it's off to the
side of that white stone now this move
were totally unthinkable to all the
professionals in the NGO world and I
just want to take a moment to try and
explain to you why this move was so
creative and so unthinkable in the game
of Go there are two important lines on
this 19 by 19 board there's the third
line here now if you play a stone on the
third line what you're saying to your
opponent is you're trying to surround
territory to the side of the board so
this is how you get points at the end of
the game so you're trying to claim
territory instead of that if you play on
the fourth line what you're saying to
your ponent is you can take territory on
the third line but I'm going to take
power and influence into the center of
the board and the idea of playing on the
fourth line is that later on in the game
that power and influence will translate
into points and territory somewhere else
on
bored now for three thousand years of
human study and contemplating this game
the third and fourth lines were
considered to be equal so if you play in
the third line your opponent plays in
the fourth line that's more or less an
equal exchange but instead of that
alphago played on the fifth line and
this is completely still thought to be
an unthinkable idea because if you play
on the fifth line you're giving your
opponent territory from the fourth line
so they're getting much more territory
for your influence but alphago seems to
like this move and moves like this so it
may be that for three thousand years
humans have been under estimating the
power and the use of this influence
towards the center of the board and sort
of underrating its value so later on the
interesting thing about go is that it's
considered to be more than just the game
in in China and Japan and Korea it's
considered to be more like an art form
something more akin to poetry in fact
Confucius wrote about go as one of the
four arts that had to be mastered by any
true scholar and the nice thing about go
is not only is it art it's actually
objective part because you know any one
of us here could come up with some
random move which would be creative in
the sense that no professional would
have thought of it but what makes this
move truly creative is the fact that it
ended up working it ended up winning the
game this game too is critical game two
because of this move so what happened is
that around fifty moves later these two
stones I've marked on the left hand
corner here with the white triangles
ended up spilling into the center of the
board the fighting from the left-hand
corner and around fifty moves later that
fighting ended up joining up with the
stone that moves thirty seven stone on
the right hand side and that stone was
perfectly positioned to tip the balance
of that site in favor of alphago and
that's why won the match of course Lisa
Dahl himself was inspired to come up
with his own incredible moving game for
which is the game that he won on mu 78 I
haven't got time to explain to you why
this was so incredible but also this
move will probably go down in history
too now the interesting thing about
alphago's moves is that
I just showed you that moves 37 alphago
gave that move a probability of 1 in
10,000 so in some sense the alphago
system knew that this move was very
unusual because it gave the probability
that human would play that move as one
in 10,000 so it wasn't just learning
what and copying what humans do it was
actually innovating so the impact of the
alphago match was huge 218 million
people watched the 5 games across across
that week 35,000 press articles and my
favorite statistic was the sales of
online board get go boards was sold out
across the world for the next month as
people picked up this great game I just
want to take a moment to discuss
intuition and creativity which i think
is what alphago is demonstrated here now
I sort of used the word intuition quite
a lot but what do I mean by it well I
think one operational definition one
useful way to think about intuition is
that it's implicit knowledge there's
been acquired through experience but it
can't be consciously expressed or
communicated now you might ask well if
you can't express it or even access it
consciously how do you know that
knowledge is there well we can test
implicit knowledge and neuroscientists
know this by testing it behaviorally it
can verify and test it behaviorally and
we'd go of course it's very easy you can
give somebody a go position and you can
test what move would they come up with
and verify the quality of that move so
what about creativity then so creativity
one operational definition of that would
be the ability to synthesize knowledge
that you have you picked up through
experience to produce a novel or
original idea in the service of some
goal now I'm not saying that encompasses
all of creativity but I think that
captures some of the essence of
creativity and at least by these two
operational definitions I feel that
alphago has clearly demonstrated these
abilities throughout these games albeit
of course in a constrained domain of the
board game go so you might think well we
beat the you know the world's best
player what else was there left to do
with go
well actually we continue to work on
this
system alphago for the next nine months
and we're still working right now
and we're working on it because we
wanted to explore the limits of
knowledge this idea of exploring the
frontiers of knowledge we first wanted
to fix the knowledge gaps that we saw in
game four that caused us to lose that
game against Lisa doll we wanted to
optimize the performance of the system
we wanted to kind of give back to the
NGO community without forego and help
improve human play through them being
able to explore and test themselves
against alphago but in short what we're
after was the scientific idea of trying
to create perfection and understand what
that was and here we had a domain where
we could potentially try and do that and
earlier actually just over Christmas and
early in the new year just just a couple
of weeks ago I'm pleased to say that we
released a new version about to go
online and it won our 60 nil against all
the world's top 20 players on the two
most popular online go servers including
the current world number one coach a who
we beat three nil which was really
astounding and it's caused huge waves in
Asia again not only again did it win 60
nil but those games are now being
studied in all these professional go
schools and new books are being written
and and and old books are being
rewritten about theory about go because
of these new innovations that alphago
has come up with and here are two more
playing in as black here in the bottom
right hand corner another unthinkable
move or here on the right hand side
against the world number two crawling
along the second line which is both of
these things were considered to be
extremely bad ideas in go theory and
alphago has shown that they're very
plausible in certain types of positions
and then interestingly the reaction of
the go world afterwards there was some
really interesting quotes from these top
go players so this is koji the Chinese
and world number one and he said
humanity's go has played go for
thousands of years and yet as AI has
shown us we have not yet even scratched
the surface
and he said the union of human and
computer players were ushered in a new
era together mankind and AI can finally
find the truth of go and that's how they
very much see go the game of Go is is
kind of almost like the way scientists
would see would see their discovery of
the natural world they feel they're
discovering the universe through this
game so people are talking about this is
a new era and go and there is precedent
for this in the 1930s and 40s this
incredible go player called Gosai again
changed the face of go and improved
people by several several notches
through his new theories and new ideas
and there's been theories in go like
this go sigh again being the most recent
one and people have been men thinking
and saying this is now the third era of
go with alphago's new innovations and I
think the alphago will actually make
human players better and you can sort of
ask why didn't chess programs when they
beat Garry Kasparov really make chess
players materially better Magnus Carlsen
who is now is the current world champion
and is a fantastic player but probably
about the same level as Garry Kasparov
was at his height the same rating and I
think the reason that is is that chess
programs are better tactically so they
calculate more they don't make mistakes
they have things like opening an endgame
databases so these are all things that
the computer is better at than the human
and really humans can't learn from that
you know we can't just calculate more or
be told don't make mistakes
obviously the chess players are trying
not to make mistakes so that doesn't
really help
whereas alphago is actually better
strategically and somatically now has
new ideas about the game and these ideas
can be analyzed and absorbed and
potentially used by the best human
players and we're already seeing that
even a couple of weeks after these 60
matches all these new innovations
proliferation of new innovations and I
think I actually think it this is opened
up the human go professional world's
eyes that actually maybe that humans
were stuck in a local Maxima for 3,000
years and we've only just realised that
now and actually some of the go players
have been saying their minds having seen
alphago their minds have been freed they
feel like they've been freed from this
cage of tradition so they can actually
go in
explore for themselves all sorts of new
ideas I think this is really interesting
in future when we think about humans and
machines together and I think that
they're humans and machines
collaborating together in a
complementary way will allow us to
achieve really amazing things and I
think of AI is this incredibly powerful
tool that will augment human ingenuity
and unlock our true potential
in fact one way you can think about AI
and indeed alphago is like AI think of
it as analogous to the Hubble telescope
a kind of ultimate tool to explore the
universe of course for go players
alphago was allowing them to explore
their universe of the game of go and I
think there are many other domains in
the real world that suffer from this
kind of combinatorial explosion that go
has now obviously as I said at the
beginning we test our systems on games
because they're the most convenient way
to develop our AI algorithms but
obviously ultimately we're not
interested in just being good at games
we want to translate those algorithms
into the real world and be useful and
make huge impact on real world
situations and one reason we could
believe we can do that is because we're
building general-purpose learning
systems they're not being handcrafted
for the gate for the switch sake like
chess they've actually we've actually
built we believe general-purpose
algorithms that could be taken from the
games that we test them on and apply to
real world so here are two areas that
we're looking at that have this kind of
iterative optimization process drug
discovery material design but there are
many many other domains as well that
could benefit from this type of
algorithmic exploration and we're
applying these to all sorts of other
areas healthcare robotics and even
optimizing data centers so a variation
of alphago we took over a last summer
and we applied it to Google's data
centers and we managed to save 15% of
the power that was used in those data
centers by controlling the cooling
systems more efficiently 40% more
efficiently so obviously this is
saves tens of millions of dollars in
terms of power usage and of course is
great for the environment and we think
that we could use these same algorithms
perhaps on entire national energy grids
which are in some ways much bigger
versions of these data centers so this
is one exciting area that we think we
can apply these kinds of algorithms to
and I'm just going to finish by coming
back to that point two of our mission
statement and the idea of what I call is
better solutions so I think in the world
today we're faced with some really
complex situations all these systems we
would like to master from disease to
macroeconomics to particle physics
contain enormous amounts of data now
we're kind of deluged by information
when the complexity of these systems is
so high in some cases bordering on on
chaotic systems that we have to confront
the idea that maybe they're too complex
for humans to understand unaided and it
presents huge challenges for us today as
a society and I think solving AI and
having this incredible system as a tool
that we can use and deploy is
potentially kinda meta solution to many
of these are other problems
now obviously AIA is a very powerful
technology and like all powerful new
technologies it must be used ethically
and responsibly and we're in the
vanguard of trying to do that and along
with several other big companies we
created earlier last year the
partnership on AI so the beneficial use
of AI for all the societies that
everyone benefits from it and there's a
lot more to come on that front and my
personal dream is that once we've
cracked AI what I'd like to do is use it
to create AI scientist or a I assisted
science to help drive science and
medicines breakthroughs as fast as
possible
thanks for listening
[Applause]
you
you